gary got an old black and white camera
now he's taking black and white film
no but he hasn't i don't i don't get one
it's the one i've had since high school
but he took uh
he took a picture of his dog for us so
bad he put the dog like right in the
center
and i was just like god gary's not
artistic at all i mean
i mean like like like he's walking
around with this black and white camera
and his composition is to put the object
the the object right in the center
you know he doesn't know the rule of
thirds it's just is a disaster
he's gonna be the king of the ordinary
picture
right it's so ordinary it's like a
picture that he could have taken easily
with his iphone
you know what i mean there was nothing
artistic about it
he's gonna use special equipment to take
an ordinary pic
yeah it was just like the dog's head
floating in the middle of this uh
picture it was just a mess
i hadn't shot film in 35 years i picked
up a camera
the first role i shot i'm like let me
see what i can do
i love this he hadn't shot yeah you know
why you hadn't shot film in a while
because nobody's using film anymore
that's right there you go
i hadn't shot film in a while i hadn't
churned butter either
well why don't you start churning butter
then maybe i will
right build a wagon wheel hey what else
haven't you done in a while
gary you've been shot filming a while
you haven't walked five miles i haven't
faxed anybody in a few years
it hasn't telegramed anybody
mary where's my rotor oh there we go
i know i know that i know that i've made
a complete ass of myself when robin has
to take out the tissues because she's
crying
she's crying look at her look at that i
[ __ ] hate when you do that robin
gary gary hasn't shot film in a while
[Laughter]
yeah i've been happy i haven't shot in
it and you know if you're gonna really
you know if you if you're annie
leibowitz and you want to really go back
and shoot film
you know you're going to play with the
depth you're going to play with the
warmth you're going to play with the
saturation you're going to you know
you're going to develop
a style unique style maybe do you know
you're shooting in sepia
it was none of that it was just this
dog's head howard you know what i mean
i'm just trying to figure out how to i'm
just trying to figure out how to get the
f-stop right
why started it gary just i'm gonna give
you my iphone you'll shoot all the
pictures you want
and you always make him look black and
white
well his hobbies are crazy he always
comes out with these terms that just
slay me
you know the first time he said i have
pieces of vinyl
and today it was a hat and shot on film
who are you friends
you